i brought a little tube whose ends have
been colored black and orange and i'm
going to
launch it into spin and it will spin
around the middle and because it's
spinning around the middle a priority
there's no reason why you should see
black better than orange orange better
than black okay but now when i launch
what we see
we see black and
every time we seem to be seen black
that's really funny we seem to be seeing
black but you don't like black i'm going
to shake it
and launch it and now
we see orange instead that's really
curious it's not a matter of launching
from right to left because i can launch
it with my left hand and it's
still orange after you don't like orange
then so i'm going to rub it against my
black hair that changes the color again
and it's black
so the first
mystery is why sometimes do we see black
and sometimes orange mystery number two
is when i launch this how many black
spots do we see i think we see four
y4 it's not as if i'm launching it with
very much care it's initial conditions
seem to be random so why do we see four
when it's stabilized it's four
and i have to shake it right
and
four oranges
in order to understand it better i
brought another tube
similarly marked black and orange now
this time i'm going to show you black
there's a much longer transient
otherwise you have to wait for it but
when it settles into steady state
we have
three again
we see three that's interesting you
might have noticed
i hope you didn't that
when i
launch from the black end
it shows black and when i press down the
orange end and launch
it's orange
so why is this
i'd like to begin by giving you a zeroth
order theory and then we'll do the full
theory later on so the zeroth order
theory goes as follows you see this
motion i'm pressing down making spin
can be thought of as a combination
superposition of two motions first the
whole thing is spinning like this around
the vertical axis we shall call it the
revolution yeah
at the same time this thing spins around
its own
axle
and we shall call that motion rotation
and the whole thing is a combination of
revolution and rotation let's say for
the time being that we launch it by
pressing down the black okay always
and
please look at the other point here at
orange end that point will be advancing
like this because of the revolution
but you see the
rotation that i gave the black hand is a
backspin like this which means that the
orange end is going in the top spin
so that's a rotation which is also going
forward yeah so the revolution makes it
advance like this but rotation which is
like like this is making go like that
also so the rotation and revolution add
to each other so this end is going fast
in contrast let's look at the black end
that i pinched down well again the
revolution revolution will make it
advanced like this
but at this end the rotation is backspin
so the rotational speed is actually
pointing backward so those two speeds
subtract from each other so this end is
going to move slower
and the fact of the matter is that the
end that we see better is the end that's
moving slower and the end that's moving
faster we don't see so well so black end
is moving slower and the orange end is
moving faster and the zeroth order
theory is that black end is the slow end
is the one and that we see and the
orange end the first end we don't see
so far so good but you see this
explanation zero sword as i called it is
not totally satisfying because first of
all why is it that we see this slow end
rather than fast and it sounds plausible
but maybe human eyes have a you know
preferred frequency that he wants to
capture and maybe at some frequency even
if it's fast we see best and so on maybe
and also this zeroth order expansion
doesn't do anything to explain y4y3
so we'll wade into the now full analysis
it so happens that when you
pinch it initially you see everything is
sliding because i'm launching it but
soon the sliding motion goes into
rolling motion rolling by the way means
the following thing when two bodies roll
against each other it means that at the
point of contact there's no relative
velocity in other words these two bodies
are moving exactly the same way that's
what rolling means
if they have a relative velocity if
they're not moving the same way at point
of contact they slide against each other
that makes sense so they roll against
each other that means that their
relative velocity is zero at the point
of contact but if an object is rolling
on the fixed floor where the flow is not
moving so that means that the point of
contact at any instant is
instantaneously at rest has zero
velocity at the point of contact that's
what rolling means so let's say it
starts rolling like this and it goes
around around directly
okay
now as you can see
it's tilted a little but let's ignore
this tilt for the moment it's very very
small and it just keeps going around
right the point of contact then is
describing a large circle on the floor
on that large circle you can see there's
a cross-sectional circle of the cube
which is you can imagine a coin rolling
on the circle like this going around
around okay so there's a small circle
rolling on the large circle
well how many times does a small circle
roll on the large circle well it has to
do with of course the perimeter of the
small circle to the perimeter of a large
circle but that's equal to the ratio of
the diameter of the small circle to the
diameter of the light circle which is
approximately the length of this thing
so it's really the aspect ratio of how
long it is to how wide it is and that's
it turns out four to one
by the way it looks a bit curious i
think most people looking at this tube
would say that it's longer and thinner
than fourth one but actually it is
because for example these two have the
same
width and if i measure this in units of
this small one that's one two three four
so it is really fourth one i don't know
why human eyes so think of it as longer
and thinner than four one but it is four
to one and that's three to one and that
is the number that we were seeing four
points four dots and three dots but
there is something even more beautiful
going on so let me go into this
we have been sort of neglecting this
slight tilt but actually there is a
slight tilt when i launch this
it so happens that the path that i push
down starts immediately rises ahead and
goes into this motion why does it rise
its head well it's easy but
an awkward explanation it has to do with
the gyroscopic effect so let me slide
over that then let's accept that it rise
raises its head and starts going like
this while this thing is rolling rolling
with a slight tilt against the floor in
steady state in your imagination please
place a transparent seedling from above
so as the touch distill the tube from
above this motion is happening between
two planes the ceiling turns imaginary
sitting above and then the real flow
below
well you can see that there is an up and
down symmetry between the flow and
ceiling of this motion it's just going
around around right like that so in
particular if this thing thing is
rolling on the floor at the bottom
at the top it's rolling under the
ceiling on the ceiling or under the
ceiling rather this thing is describing
a large circle and this sort of coin
like cross-sectional circle is hanging
from the ceiling circle going around
around in a circle
rolling means as we explained that in
fact instantaneously whatever point is
the point of contact with the with the
ceiling is instantaneously at rest
because it's now touching the ceiling
from below yeah so oh yeah we said
something to the effect that well the
black end is the slower and then the
orange end is the first end but never
mind slow it's actually instantaneously
at rest the velocity becomes zero every
time it comes up it
puff goes stops for us and that's why we
see them so clearly and how many times
did they stop per circuit well four
exactly because that's the ratio aspect
ratio that we talked about
stopping four times
in every possible position too though
it's not just stopping with the black
part up it's stopping ah that's right
but you see the
in other positions we are seeing the
white bit stop
so between the black bits in fact you
see lots and lots of variety bits that
are stopping for us and that's why we
see in fact a white circle with four
black dots okay indeed so every point
whenever it comes upward is stopped
similarly every point down below is
stopping whenever it comes into the
point of contact so if you did this
experiment maybe you would like to do it
together between not just a flow like
this but to say glass floor and
transparent flow and we filmed from
below then we would see the orange bits
boom boom boom boom
and then all the rest will be white
there is a very beautiful curve called
the cycloid so cycloid is roughly
speaking this curve if you look at the
trajectory of this black thing as the
the cross-sectional circle rows i'm
going to exaggerate the size it
describes describes a curve like this
and that's called the cycloid the point
about the cycloid it has cusps you see
whenever it touches the flow the
stationary support it it has a cusp and
this cusp turns out to be
locally vertical you know it doesn't
make an angle like this but actually
it's like this because the point is
curving in and then
kind of bouncing vertically and going
out and going out so
this has the following very very
interesting consequence as well if we go
back for a moment to this motion
orange one which is touching the floor
is then describing a cycloid if you like
those lobes standing on the
circle on the floor
similarly by the same token this black
dot is describing a sequence of upside
down cycloids
whose lobes are hanging from the ceiling
like this
and each time the black dot comes up
you're at the cusp of this cycloid up
upside down cycloid but you see this
cusp is
vertical cusp and we're looking at the
motion from above you see so that means
that whenever the black dot comes into
contact with the ceiling and goes into
internet instantaneous rest not only
does it stop instantaneously but in that
vicinity it's moving only vertically
and we're looking at from above so we
see only horizontal motion and for the
observer from above vertical motion is
invisible right i mean it looks like
stationary see in other words near this
stationary point the cusp of the cycloid
when the black dot comes into contact
with the seeding from above it not only
comes it becomes stationary at that
moment but its velocity is really
exaggeratedly so the shrunk with respect
to the observer from above so not only
do you get zero velocity but
around the moment
these velocities artificially shrunk
because of the angle of the observation
that's why we see this effect so clearly
so it has the
effect of exaggerating this stop motion
now when i
started thinking about this i didn't
know of course what was happening and so
i went to a hardware store in tokyo and
i bought a long plastic tube and then
cut them in aspect ratios of integers
and then started playing with this and
figured that everything by the way if
you want to do this at home and so on i
recommend that you use hollow tubes
because you see
hollow tube means that most of the mass
is concentrated on the rim
and at the same time because it's hollow
it's not so heavy so making it light has
the advantage that you can launch it
easily
but concentrating the mass on the rim
and has the advantage that what is
called the moment of inertia is large
for the same mass so once it gets going
it gets going and it keeps going in a
stable fashion i made those things in
aspect ratios of integers four to one
three to one and so on i also have a
term five to one but i regret doing this
because you see i really would like to
know what happens when the aspect ratio
is not an integer
and instead of visiting the vertices
consecutively like this in order
what you see is that you see those dots
skipping and going every second vertex
like this like
in the beginning it's a mess